[Music]
tonight remember this cuz we're not
going to find this
again remembering Matthew Perry we have
new details on his shocking death and
how he spent his final days if you had
one more message to man what would it be
thanks for being a very good friend plus
we're with his co-stars sharing memories
his greatest gift was his heart and
tributes the kindness that is his True
Legacy why he wanted his battle with
addiction to be part of his legacy you
either lie down about it or step up to
bat and take your swing plus never
before seen interviews from the set of
friends sorry we just got to get through
hi we're here for Entertainment Tonight
with television's Courtney Cox and
television's David schwimer and the
stories behind his unbreakable bond with
the cast no I'm going to cry now it's a
very loving tight-knit group ET Starts
Now a comedy light extinguished way too
soon tonight ET remembers Matthew Perry
welcome everyone yes Matthew was
everyone's forever friend but in his
passing we are also seen how beloved he
was as a human being Kevin Frasier joins
us from outside Matthews La home a much
different scene than what you saw there
on Saturday Kev yeah Nichelle we were
here moments after the news broke and at
the time it was police cars and Chaos
today a memorial outside Matthews gate
also in New York outside the fictional
friend's apartment building in lower
Manhattan now the investigation into
Matthew's death continues but for those
who loved him there's an overwhelming
outpouring of
grief I'm always drawn to characters
that start off from somewhat broken
place I think it was just magic was
happening there was just uh the perfect
casting the perfect writers and just
sort of magic just all happened at once
hi we're here for Entertainment Tonight
with television Courtney Cox and
television's David schwimer and uh it
was funny
peot
peot paper shut up shut up shut up it
was just funny all the way through all
237 episodes here's the latest on
Matthew's death authorities have
conducted an autopsy on the actor's body
but the results are inconclusive as they
wait for more test results including
toxicology which could take weeks Foul
Play is not suspected according to one
report no illicit drugs were found at
the house but multiple Outlets citing
sources say there were various
prescription medications recovered which
will be part of the review how did you
get the courage to fight the addiction
to vicadin you get into a place in your
life where you're having a problem and
you either you know lie down about it or
step up to bat
and take your uh take your swing AG 23
rescue 23 miss all radio Miss of the
drowning at around 400 p.m. Saturday the
54-year-old was discovered unresponsive
in a hot tub here at his La home eily
just a week ago Matthew posted this pick
of himself in a hot tub in what appears
to be the same location where he was
found just around 7:30 Matthew's
stepfather Keith Morrison arrived with
other family members Keith a
correspondent for dine NBC was seen
crossing the police tape and speaking to
Matthew's grief stricken Father John
Bennett Perry the TV journalist became
Matthew's stepfather when he was 12
years old what's the best perk about
being Matthew's stepdad he is really a
very good guy had a chance to speak to
one of Matthew's neighbors a young man
named Theo said right around 4:30 he saw
police activity and then an ambulance no
they didn't Hammer the door not at all I
was very heartbroken to see what
happened Matthew was last seen out N9
days ago grabbing a meal with a friend
his last big public outing was at the
French Open 4 months ago Matthew loved
tennis but it turned his Focus to pickle
ball pickle ball I think was was an
outlet for him uh it was something that
you know he became obsessed with and
that was that was his new um healthy
addiction and he loved it ET has learned
Matthew was playing pickle ball hours
before his death I spoke to his coach
Matt manasse what was Matthew's mindset
these last few months he was in good
spirits every time I talked to him yeah
you have to be in shape to play pickle
ball how was Matthew doing physically it
seemed like he was really had turned a
corner yeah he was heading in a great
Direction and he was set to become
healthy and and uh and he was doing it
his dealings with addictions were were
very well publicized he would bring
other people to the court sometimes that
were going through similar things and
try to use pickleball to help them as
well if you had one more message to Matt
what would it
be I miss him I'd like to talk to him
one more
time yeah what would you tell him uh
just thanks thanks for being a very good
friend the tributes continue to pour in
for Matthew's friends family so
handsome you're look beautiful mom I've
been very touched this morning and and
uh yesterday I spoke with Morgan
Fairchild today she remembers her TV son
as a kind soul who battled through his
own addiction to help others did you
ever have a chance to discuss that with
him I didn't discuss it with him because
at the time I was on the set when he was
going through it I knew there were
problems I never saw it in his work and
I was so proud of him for how he'd come
through some of these hard times and had
turned to trying to help other people I
would just say Matthew well done my son
well done
hello Matthew's TV girlfriend Maggie
wheeler who played Janice shared the joy
you brought to so many in your Too Short
lifetime will live on Max added an
inmemoriam tribute to its reunion
episode and the show's co-creators and
former exact producer tell ET This truly
is the one where our hearts are broken
Matthew was uh the first friend I made
in Los Angeles we were really more like
brothers Hank aeria revealed Matthew was
instrumental in his own journey to
sobriety a lot of us who are close to
him felt like we lost him to drugs and
alcohol a long time ago he documented it
all publicly but it's heartbreaking I
know it's going to help people to talk
[Music]
about only hours after his passing the
Friends theme played at the LA Kings
game where Matthew an avid hockey fan
was often seen in the stands and SNL
honored their one-time Host this is kind
of a dream come true for me to be
hosting the show ET was on set with the
star back in 1997 the same year he
completed his first stt rehab I'm doing
great couldn't be better there's nothing
like you know just getting to go back to
the job that you love doing to just uh
make you happy so I'm doing great I love
working for my apartment yeah it's a
treat for us all so many memories came
pouring back about how kind he was ET
also spoke with Matthews The Odd Couple
co-star Evette Nicole Brown who shared
his private side that few knew his
greatest gift was his heart he lightened
loads
you know even in the midst of the
heaviness that he was carrying I was
going to say he light and loads for
everyone but himself it's yeah that's
what it feels like and um I think the
saddest thing for me and in talking to
my castmates and other people that knew
him I don't know that he ever found
peace when we were working with Matthew
we had a front row seat to um his
struggles and we loved him and we wanted
to protect him working with you has been
one of the greatest joys of my life I
really adore
you sorry that was
Matthew and that was our relationship it
was really lovely his hope and joy was
helping others to
survive what he fought for most of his
[Music]
life as for Matthew's friends role the
camera adds 10 lbs huh so how many
cameras are actually on
you Chandler was the sarcasm King but
did you know he was only supposed to be
a supporting character Matthew's comedic
timing changed all that I will not take
this abuse you're right I'm
sorry once I was a wooden
boy Matthew the over under on how many
times St you're going to hear could you
be any more excited how many times
you're going to hear that could we be
more white trash could she be more out
of my league could I be more sorry I've
heard that a lot I've heard that a lot
but I like hearing that ET first crashed
the iconic set in '94 just a few months
after they started filming FR in America
yeah I'm pretty much sick of Everybody
by now you got the key to the bathroom
you have the key to the bathroom 17
years later not much had changed shut up
over there shut up we sat down with a
gang in 2021 for their reunion on Max
our final interview with Maddie it's a
very loving tight-knit group and when we
see each other it's a it's a very
heartwarming thing should we get some
coffee
sure where it was in our DNA that we
were family we were going to take care
of each other after the show wrapped
This Crew remained close Lisa wrote a
heartfelt forward for Matthew's 2022
Memoir explaining even they weren't
privy to all of his addiction struggles
quote he has survived impossible odds
but I had no idea how many times he
almost didn't make it we weren't
equipped nobody had ever dealt with with
that Jen actually played a major role in
Matthew's journey to sobriety she says
we know you're drinking yeah imagine how
scary a moment that was she was the one
that reached out the most you know I
really grateful to her for that it was
only last year that fans begin to
understand the scope of Matthew's secret
struggle thanks to his tell all book and
his sitdown with Diane Sawyer 55 bking
on a day which is where I was
I would go to open houses and go to the
bathrooms in the open house and see what
pills they had in there and steal them
and I think they thought well there's no
way that Chandler came in and stole from
us you can track the trajectory of my
addiction if you gauge my weight from
season to season when I'm carrying
weight it's alcohol when I'm skinny it's
pills that's a guy that's out of control
I I didn't know what was going on with
me I weighed
155 lb all my way to 128 lb Matthew
spent nearly $9 million trying to get
sober attended 6,000 AA meetings went to
rehab 15 times survived 14 surgeries and
was even in a coma for 2 weeks during
the summer of 2018
escaped death really narrowly but just
how much did Matthew vote his life to
helping others I invested
$500,000 and turned my house in Malibu
into a sober living place called Perry
house Matthew set up meditation programs
and a 12-step Workshop inside his former
Malibu mansion the star championed
others in their recovery and in 2015
Lisa Kudo helped honor him for his work
very meaningful to me that Lisa agreed
to do it it's uh a really special
relationship Matthew really wanted his
struggle to be part of his legacy he he
was the friend that knew what the
darkness was like and shared it so
others wouldn't feel so alone when I die
I don't want friends to be the first
thing that's mentioned the best thing
about me Barone is if somebody comes up
to me and says I can't stop drinking can
you help me I can say yes I'm going to
live the rest of my life proving that
God is always there for me now the one
thing I got right was that I never gave
up love always wins
I'm going to use the
cushion David shmmer came into my
dressing room when we were about to
renegotiate and he said I think we
should negotiate together and I said
great
idiot Matthew Perry made many big
reveals in his Memoir including a few
Hollywood romances in 1993 just before
friends debuted he spent the summer with
a future Oscar winner this was the last
summer of my life when and I could make
out at a party with a beautiful young
woman called Gwyneth we slipped off into
a broom cupboard and made out palro
reminisced in a tribute to Matthew
writing it was a magical summer nearly 3
years later he dat one of the friends
guest stars Julia Roberts why don't you
call me in 20 years and tell me if
you're still upset about
this that was not enough I could never
be enough I was broken bent unlovable so
instead of facing the inevitable Agony
of losing her I broke up with the
beautiful and Brilliant Julia Roberts
Another One That Got Away getting to
Star opposite Merill Street oh being in
don't look up didn't work out because my
life was on fire I got CPR and the guy
who saved my life broke eight ribs with
the broken ribs there was no way I could
continue apparently on the set she was
like Matthew mat where are you wow she
missed me did does she now know is this
how she's learning what happened it's a
completely madeup
story his comedic timing was unmatched
all right there were other roles that
came Matthew's way and of course ET was
on set okay Matthew L Perry so have you
seen the sites ET first met Matthew in
1988 after landing his first big TV role
in the shortlived fox series boys will
be boys it's about it's about an all-
american guy and it's epic it's epic
while that show was canceled after one
season that same year he started
alongside Christina Applegate in the TV
movie dance till dawn we're losers uh
well you know I I I bought you that ring
it's it's a good chance for uh people to
see my work Matthew also had minor roles
in classic sitcoms like Charles in
Charge silver spoons and growing pains
well I go here sophomore by 1990 Matthew
was still full of Hope and ready for
Fame after being cast as Valerie Burton
Elli's brother in the CBS sitcom Sydney
oh I can see you're doing a sexy look
okay my sexy
look I scream okay you happy here's my
shot for people to know who I am I guess
of course that wouldn't come into
friends that success LED Matt to his
first big screen role he was the leading
man opposite Sal mahay in Fool's Rush In
And ET was on the 1996 set take one
Walker seemed like a guy that uh is a
little bit different than the guy I play
on friends you know it's nice to
actually get the girl you've seen Selma
have you today Salma posted she will
quote continue to cherish your silliness
your perseverance and your lovely heart
in 2000 Matthew co-starred with Bruce
Willis in the whole nine yards Frankie
told me what a standup guy you've
been I change your pants their
friendship led to Bruce's emmy-winning
appearance on friends which he only
agreed to after losing a bet let's see
how this movie turns out if it does well
you can be on the show and if it doesn't
it's Bruce Willis to block
yes Joey
hi
Ross after friends came to an end in
2004 Matthew made his series return in
the Aaron sorin drama Studio 60 on the
Sunset Strip I'm an executive producer
too I'm just here for this interview
that's how excited I am about this and
you and Studio 60 then there was the TV
comedy Mr Sunshine which he created yeah
I guess that's just something I can't do
we're all just trying to put on a uh
really funny show and while Matthew's
friends never appeared on any of his
series he reunited with his TV wife
Courtney Cox in 2013 making a cameo on
Cougar Town I'm just passing through on
my way to Miami I just have to keep
remembering that I don't know him in
this show she's right we have to
remember that we're not we haven't been
married for 5 years but I guess that's
what acting
is I'm not going to miss you helping me
out with money the only thing that I'm
going to
miss is
you through through friends Matthew
Perry left his mark on pop culture and
despite battling his own demons he
provided joy and laughs for all who
worked with him watched him and loved
him rest easy Matthew and good night
everyone you just have to uh basically
throw yourself into the work and keep a
good head about it this is harder than I
thought it would
be it's going to be okay it really feels
like home like we'll never have that
again like we you know I'll never have
that again and we keep reminding each
other like remember this cuz you we're
not going to find this again if one of
us bumped into each other that was it
that was the end of the night you just
sat with that sat with the person you
apologized to the people you were with
but they had to understand you had met
somebody special to you and you were
going to talk to that person for the
rest of the
night I would like to be remembered as
somebody who uh lived well loved well
and
his Paramount thing is that he wants to
help
people that's that's what I
want